alors tout d'abord rappeler parce
qu'effectivement on va donner une
version de ce qui s'est réellement passé
qui il faut le rappeler est une version
totalement différente de la version qui
a été avancé par les services de police
et notamment les syndicats policiers à
la minute près au moment où ce drame est
arrivé
souvenez vous au moment où ce drame
arrive vous les avez les syndicats de
police qui communiqué qui paradent sur
tous les plateaux de télé en disant que
effectivement un refus d'obtempérer a
failli tuer deux policiers et que ces
derniers ont dû tirer notamment pour
sauver leur vie tout du moins leur
intégrité physique sauf que sauf que le
lendemain
paraîtra une vidéo
témoignage une vidéo qui a été transmise
par à témoin et qui montrera tout autre
chose qui montrera qu effectivement à
aucun membre aucun moment le policier
qui tire sur la victime parce qu'il faut
le rappeler zyed est une victime décédée
aujourd'hui qui tire sur la victime à
bout portant
n'étant danger de mort où il y a ou ne
serait ce qu'un risque d' atteinte à son
intégrité physique et de la même façon
en ce qui concerne son collègue puisque
souvenez-vous les policiers les
syndicats de police disait
qu'effectivement c'était aussi pour
protéger la vie de son collègue et on
s'est tous rendu compte qu'il est
physiquement le collègue était dans la
voiture je voudrais rajouter à notamment
cette version mensongère l'indécence
aussi syrine eising l'indécence pourquoi
l'indécence parce que pendant que les
syndicats policiers étaient en train de
parader sur tous les plateaux la mère de
la victime la famille de la victime
n'était pas au courant
la mère de la victime a été informée
quand tu décides du décès de son fils à
une chaîne plus d'une journée plus tard
et c'est à dire qu'il y avait des gens
qui ap le commissaire de police parce
qu'effectivement ça va vite vous le
savez est effectivement le nom zied
étaient déjà sortis et lorsque des
personnes appelé le commissariat pour
savoir si c'était bien ziad qui était
décédé le commissariat ne donnait pas de
réponse mais pendant ce temps là et
c'est pour ça que je parle d' indécence
les syndicats de police parader sur tous
les plateaux télévisés en train de
donner une version totalement
contradictoire avec la réalité qui est
prouvé par une vidéo alors j'aimerais
avoir aussi de la vie de mettre ses fans
gays ou pour vous avez la même version
bien entendu que m hélas ma bouche vous
êtes les deux avocats donc de la famille
des victimes tels faits qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour ce que vous pouvez
raconter à nos téléspectateurs votre
version des faits écoutez pour nous
c'est assez insupportable de constater
que dans ce type de dossier manière
systématique on a les syndicats de
police qui viennent couvrir
un homicide volontaire puis ce qu'il
faut le dire de manière très concrète et
nous expliquait toujours qu'en réalité
il ya toujours cette inversion ça qui
nous est vraiment insupportable
on vient accusé la victime
d'avoir eu un comportement délictueux
moi je voudrais poser une question
fondamentale c'est de savoir en quoi
lorsque le policier tire lorsqu'on tue
des gens pour des refus d'obtempérer
la société se porte mieux et moi j'ai
trouvé ça indécent comme l'a dit mon
confrère plus encore d'entendre ces
syndicats de police n'ont pas partagé ne
serait ce qu'un petit peu d'empathie
vis-à-vis de la famille ne serait-ce
qu'à piquer qu'un petit peu de pitié à
la gare de la famille mais venir juste
nous nous faire pleurer et nous faire
dire que le policier était sous le choc
et le jeu et moi je voudrais préciser
parce que les témoins aujourd'hui
viennent nous parler nous expliquer que
le policier qui a tiré est resté plus de
vingt minutes sans réagir sans tenter de
faire un massage cardiaque il a fait
attendre que les pompiers arrivent pour
venir tenter de sauver de sauver y est
mais le policier était plus occupé à
s'allonger pour respirer a demandé une
bouteille d'eau ou appeler sa femme
plutôt que s'occuper d'eux y est et nous
on trouve ça insupportable insupportable
de savoir que la hiérarchie politique la
hiérarchie policière et les politiques
parce qu'il faut le dire en réalité on
se retrouve dans cette situation parce
qu'il ya une réforme en 2017 qui permet
par un ajout dans le code de la sécurité
intérieure à des policiers de sortir de
dudu 4 qui était initialement celui de
la légitime défense pour venir nous
expliquer qu'on peut tirer on peut tirer
sur des individus et nous on s'interroge
pourquoi la hiérarchie policière
pourquoi les politiques ne viennent pas
nous dire que c'est un drame que c'est
une tragédie et que en l'espèce n'était
pas nécessaire de tirer était pas
nécessaire de tuer michel thooris
secrétaire général du syndicat france
police qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
de cette affaire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter vous ce qui s'est passé
déjà je pense qu'il ya une vidéo qui
circule sur internet qui est partiel qui
monte partiellement les faits mais qui
montre défi extrêmement clair on a un
individu tout à fait déterminé qui
refuse de s'arrêter qui percute la
voiture des collègues et on sait
évidemment que dans sa fuite il va soit
tué des passants comme s'était récemment
le cas dans plusieurs affaires le site
duratorq du restaurateur qui a été tuée
par un chauffard tant d'autres
s'affairent qu on pourrait citer
effectivement le collègue vous l'avez
dit avec beaucoup de justesse m il ya eu
une réforme il ya un texte qui permet à
mes collègues d'ouvrir le feu le
collègue a fait preuve de beaucoup de
discernement il a évité des morts il a
évité d'autres morts il a tiré
l'individu a choisi il aurait pu
s'arrêter il a continué le collègue a
tiré et je pense qu'il faut pas tomber
dans l'inversion comme vous le faites
alors est-ce
qu'il était dans la presse il ya des
infos qui ont circulé comme qu'elle
circulait sans permis à bord d'un vieux
que moi moi je n'ai pas accès au dossier
donc je rentrerai pas là dessus et peu
importe moi je juge sur les faits qui se
sont produits on voit que cet individu a
refusé d'obtempérer il était déterminé
il a percuté la voiture de police le
collègues étaient tout à fait fondés à
attirer la preuve la justice va
aujourd'hui dans son sens en ne mettant
pas en cause pour homicide volontaire et
simplement pour violences quant à voir
la vidéo
[Musique]
voilà
en question
[Musique]
ça tire ça tire
oh
on put y en
a des images voilà
c'est compliqué de revoir ces images
donc pour vous là il a eu la bonne
attitude je pense qu'il faut arrêter
d'inverser les valeurs aujourd'hui la
véritable victime dans cette affaire
c'est mon collègue imaginez le
traumatisme que c'est aujourd'hui pour
le collègue d'avoir ouvert le feu les
avocats l'ont rappelé le collègue était
en état de choc après après avoir fait
feu on subit aujourd'hui en france un
refus d'obtempérer toutes les 30 minutes
nous sommes le seul pays aujourd'hui
parmi les pays les plus avancés en
termes de droits de l'homme je pense
notamment à nos confrères anglais c'est
que mes collègues en angleterre
aujourd'hui applique le contact tactique
sur les refus d'obtempérer il shoote
avec le véhicule avec les risques que
cela peut avoir il faut aujourd'hui que
les individus apprennent à s'arrêter à
obtempérer aux forces de l'ordre on ne
peut pas continuer en france en laissant
tout faire vous savez que notre
hiérarchie chez aujourd'hui nous
interdit de prendre en chasse les
véhicules ça veut dire qu'on est dans
une situation aujourd'hui d' impunité
absolue un individu refuse de s'arrêter
il peut transporter de la drogue il peut
avoir commis un braquage il peut être
dans une action terroriste
on ne peut pas le prendre en chasse donc
à un moment donné il faut que les choses
s'arrêtent mon organisation syndicale le
syndicat france police policiers en
colère nous on milite pour une réforme
de la légitime défense on estime
aujourd'hui que le texte ne va pas assez
loin il faut retirer du texte de notion
celle de proportionnalité et d'absolue
nécessité qui sont des notions
absolument floués qui laisse la porte à
toutes les interprétations
jurisprudentielles la vie la justice
chico dit quoi aujourd'hui la justice à
leur connaît évidemment la légitime
défense pour le lycée alors à y avoir
une manif peut tuer la corée les avoir
la gentillesse ne reconnaît absolument
pas pour l'instant légitime défense il
aurait été mis en cause non aujourd'hui
les mises en examen pour violences ayant
entraîné la mort sans intention de la
donner à whisler du team défense
d'accord ici donc ça c'est la première
des choses deuxièmement vous le savez
très bien quand on suit un dossier
judiciaire il ya un fort risque de
requalification
il ya donc beaucoup de dossiers wifi
commence à s 21 qui commence notamment
de cette façon et qui se termine par la
qualification d'homicide volontaire et
ça vous le savez très bien et là quand
vous dites quand j'entends monsieur
touriste et je vous entends dire il
faudrait enlever ces notions un peu flou
l'absolue nécessité la stricte
proportionnalité
qu'est-ce que vous demander monsieur
touristes habitué à la française que
vous demande réduite seront différents
tuer pour damon ce onze de si monsieur
si effectivement les cibles sont
encadrés par celui-ci de
proportionnalité qui va dire à ce moment
là qui va encadrer à quel moment on peut
tirer et on peut prendre la vie d'une
personne parce que concrètement c'est ce
qui s'est passé tirer aujourd'hui prend
le risque de tirer c'est prendre le
risque d'enlever la vie d'une personne
et d'ailleurs cette indécence parce
qu'aujourd'hui monsieur touriste nous
paraît effectivement extrêmement oppose
etc cyril encore une fois je dis comme
c'est important et pour rebondir sur ce
qu'a dit tout à l'heure mon confrère
l'inversement la victime c'est celui qui
est mort est ce que vous savez monsieur
touriste quelle est la peine aujourd'hui
du refus d'obtempérer quelle est la
peine mais c'est un problème suis allé
l'axé un problème d'antenne problème
heureux de la peine est en prenant la
peine de un an et 7500 euros d'amendé
d'accord il à dire que le russe avait
bien acceptée à dire en danger de la vie
d'autrui aujourd'hui une conduite sans
permis pour un refus d'obtempérer et je
veux bien entendre tout ce qu'on veut
mais personne ne me fera croire ici
qu'il n'a pas des connaissances qui
parfois ont conduit en état
d'alcooliques ont fait des et réjean st
pu produire des erreurs des gens se sont
pas arrêtés ont pu effectivement dépassé
le taux d'alcoolémie xetra alors ici la
famille dia dit une chose que il y ait
eu une procédure judiciaire que ce
dernier pu être traduits en justice mais
qu'on laisse au moins la possibilité aux
parents de continuer embrasser leur
offrait vous nous et sa gouaille et à le
chien est la mère de d'arrêt pour une
peine d'un an c'est extrêmement grave
est et j'ajoute ce tourisme le fait
qu'aujourd'hui sa mère et elle avait
raison
il sera administré à quoi ils ont
continué à dire parce que effectivement
parce que il a fallu courir ce crime
policiers parce que c'est un crime
policiers et on a commencé effectivement
à charge et zied en dix ans et six aides
seraient peut-être aussi un passeur de
migrants etc etc je tiens à dire un
certain de choses que d'abord nous avons
un certain nombre d'informations que
nous allons communiquer au juge
d'instruire
et de communiquer là dessus nous avons
un certain nombre d'informations qui
contredit totalement cette thèse quant
aux face à la façon d'appréhender
quant à la façon d'appréhender y est il
ya vous avez fait référence à d'autres
pays et notamment effectivement au sein
la bloutière il ya les italiens et les
français mais vous savez comment ils
essaient d'arrêter en tirant en dans le
tas il et on aurait pu effectivement est
d'autant plus qu'on on a vous avez
repasser la vidéo tire dans le tas on
voit que la voiture est bloquée on
aurait pu crever les pneus on aurait pu
voilà c'est ce qu'ils voient c'est ici
je vais quand même vous répondre sur
cette aberration dès de crever on a
beaucoup de gens qui disent haro ne l'aï
jamais dans les pneus pour une raison
simple déjà c'est pas évident de toucher
le pneu et si le collègue tire à côté
l'ogive va poursuivre sa course et on va
battre un passant on n'est pas au far
west accord le tir on demande à
l'individu de s'arrêter si à un moment
donné on rentre dans le cadre de la
légitime défense le collègue chez feu
c'est un gars tire pas dans les pneus on
tire pas dans l'immense île veut attirer
dans le thorax mais pas dans l'autre ne
si je comprends bien votre logique
fonctionne pas dans les pneus c'est pas
prévu au niveau admissible de cirey sur
la dérive au mieux tiré dans la tête ou
dans le thorax alors qu'il savait
d'ailleurs y compris au sein de votre
réglementation noté qu'ils fonctionnent
alité que vous l'enlever et notamment
l'appui de nécessité mais justement ça
qui encadrent et qui fait en sorte qu'on
passe edouard baer sim est merci m si
chaîne casey's merci m et dans ma bouche
on va suivre la faire on à vos boules
avoir votre version aujourd'hui merci
michel thooris d'être venu